all right we're gonna go ahead and get
started and then consistent with this
theme of this section we're gonna be
optimistic under uncertainty and hope
that this will work but we will see
before we get into the content I want to
ask if anybody has any questions about
logistics or any other aspects of the
general Garcia we're doing the default
project are okay either not submitting
or just submitting another thing for the
milestones doing the default so the
question was asking about to repeat the
question was asking about whether or not
people who are doing the default project
if they need to do anything in
particular for the milestone no ok so
just as a reminder where we are sort of
in the class right now is um last time
we started talking about bandits and
regret and we'll do a brief recap of
that today and we're gonna continue to
talk about fast learning and we're gonna
go from Bayesian bandits towards Markov
decision processes today and then on
Wednesday we're gonna talk some more
about fast learning and then we're gonna
try to talk about so fast learning and
exploration and just to remind us all
about like why we're doing this um the
idea was that if we want to move
reinforcement learning into real world
applications we need to think about
carefully taking the data that we have
and how do we gather it and how do we
best use it so that we don't need to
collect a lot of data in order for our
agents to learn to make good decisions
and one of my original interest in this
whole topic was to think sort of
formally about what does it mean for an
agent to learn to make good decisions
and what are this roof
information-theoretic limits of how much
information would an agent need in order
to be able to make a provably optimal
decision so we've been thinking about
sort of a couple different main things
here we're talking about a couple
settings last time we talked about
bandits today we also talked about
bandits the Markov decision processes
we're talking about frameworks which are
ways for us to formally assess how good
an algorithm is you know these could be
the framework of empirical success
we talked last time about the
mathematical framework of regret and
we'll talk today about some other
frameworks for evaluating in general how
go-to reinforcement learning algorithm
and then we're also talking about styles
of approaches that tend to allow us to
achieve these different frameworks and
last time what we started to do is to
talk about optimism under uncertainty so
just a quick recap from bandits so a
bandit was basically a simplified
version of Markov decision process where
in the most simple setting there's no
state there's a set of actions and now
we're gonna think specifically about the
fact that the reward is through some
stochastic distribution there's some
unknown probability distribution over
rewards and each time step you get to
select an action and seeing a reward and
then your goal is to select actions in a
way that is gonna optimize your rewards
over time and the reason this was
different than a supervised learning
problem is that you only get to observe
the reward for the action that you
sample so it's what's known as sensor
data you don't get to see what would
have happened if you'd went to Harvard
so we get to see sensor data and we have
to use that sensor data to make good
decisions and when we discussed here
talking about regret
what we mean that in a formal
mathematical sense is that we were
comparing the expected reward from the
action we took to the expected reward of
the optimal action now notice that all
of these things are stochastic so it
doesn't have to have a particular
parametric distribution but imagine that
we're thinking about gaussians and let's
say we had two gaussians so this is
action to and this is action one okay so
here the mean of action one so skew of a
one is greater than Q a a two so action
one has the better expected reward but
notice that on any particular trial you
might sometimes get it you could may
imagine getting your result where the
actual reward you get from a suboptimal
arm is better than the expected reward
of the optimal arm I just want to
highlight that so imagine that you'd
sampled from action a two and you got
here is a particular sample
so you could have a particular sample be
better than the expected reward at the
optimal erm but because we're imagining
doing this many many times we're again
just looking at expectations
so we're saying on average which is the
best arm and on average how much do we
lose from selecting a suboptimal arm and
the goal was to minimise our total
regret which is equivalent to maximizing
our cumulative reward over time so we
then introduced this idea of optimism
under of under uncertainty and the idea
was to estimate an upper confidence
bound on the potential expected reward
of each of the arms so this was to say
we want to be able to say for each of
the arms what do we think it's an upper
bound of their expected value and then
when we act
we're gonna pick whichever arm has the
highest upper confidence bound and this
was going to lead to one of two outcomes
so this could um two things could happen
so either either a t is equal to a star
and in that case what's our regret 0 so
if we select the optimal action and we
have a regret of 0 so that's good then
we have a regret of 0 like a per time
step or it's not and if it's not on
average what happens to that upper
confidence bound
yeah
yes yes that is correct so we lower it
so if we get if we select an arm which
is not optimal then it means it's real
mean is lower and then the upper
confidence bound were averaging at least
with high probability and so then in
general our UT of 80 will decrease so
we're going to gain information about
what the real mean is of that arm and
we'll reduce it and if we reduce it
enough over time we should find that the
optimal arms upper confidence bound is
higher so I'll ask you today about what
might happen if we do lower bounds and
but that's one of the reasons why upper
bounds is really good and and I
mentioned that these ideas have really
been around for a long time at least
around like 20 25 to 30 years so I think
the first one was 1993 helbling by
Leslie Kelly and she's at MIT I don't
remember if it was her PhD thesis or it
was just after that but she talked about
this idea of interval estimation of
estimating the potential rewards she
didn't do formal proofs of this being a
good idea but she did it for Markov
decision processes and they found that
it was a very good idea in terms of
empirical performance and then a lot of
people went around and did the
theoretical analysis and showed that
provably this is a good thing and I
think it's interesting often about which
area ends up being a more advanced
whether it's the empirical side or the
theoretical side okay so optimism under
uncertainty the bandit case just
involves keeping track of the rewards
we've seen and we showed saw that we
could use things like huff ting
inequality to compute these upper
confidence bounds because remember each
of our samples from the arms is iid
because they're all coming from the same
parametric distribution which is unknown
and we're giving these samples so what
we found last time is that I if we use
the upper competence bound algorithm I
did a proof on the board to show that
with high probability we had logarithmic
regret why was this important because we
looked at greedy algorithms and showed
that they could have linear regret and
what is it linear in so um this is in
the number of time steps number of time
steps we act
so why is linear regret bad well if it's
linear it means that essentially you
could be making the worst decision all
in every single time point and that's
pretty bad so we'd like to have things
that are growing slower which means that
our algorithm is essentially learning to
make good decisions now notice that in
this case this is a little bit different
statement of a result than what we saw
before it's related this involves the
gaps this is the gaps Delta a is equal
to Q of a star minus Q of a how much
worse it is to take a particular action
than to take the optimal action and this
is related to a bit different to the
bound from last time last time we proved
a bound that was independent of the gaps
so it didn't matter what the gaps are in
the problem and this is a bound that
depends on the gaps now of course you
don't know what the gaps are in practice
if you did know the gaps then you would
know the optimal arm to prove but the
nice thing about this is that it's
always important to know whether or not
this sort of knowledge appears in the
analysis or in the algorithm this is
saying you don't need to know what the
gaps are but if you use this algorithm
how your law how your regret grows
depends on a property of the domain you
don't have to know the property of that
domain but that's what your regret will
depend on and so this is saying that for
upper confidence bounds if you have
different sizes of gaps you're going to
get different regrets for your algorithm
is just going to proceed by following up
our confidence bounds it doesn't need to
know about these gaps you're gonna get
better or worse performance depending on
what they caps are and in general we'd
really like these we'd like our
algorithms to be able to adapt to the
problem so that the this is known as a
problem dependent bound right here and
you would like those you'd like to have
algorithms that are agnostic they
provide problem dependent bounds so they
work better if the problem is easier all
right so let's go to our toy example
which we were talking about as a way to
sort of see how these different
algorithms work
and we were looking at fake ways to
treat broken toes and where we're
looking at surgery buddy taping or doing
nothing and we were imagining that we
had a bernoulli variable that determined
whether or not these treatments worked
so surgery on an expectation was the
most expect most effective thing with
0.95 success
buddy taping was 0.9 and doing nothing
was 0.1 so how would something like
upper confidence bound algorithms work
well the beginning won't have any data
so let's sample all of the arms once
that's gonna involve sampling from a
Bernoulli distribution so in this case
let's imagine that we got a 1 a 2 and a
3 here and note that this is this is our
empirical estimate where we just
averaged over all the all the rewards
we've seen from a particular arm so we
took pulled each arm once which same is
taking each action once we got 1 1 0 and
now what we have to do is compute the
upper confidence bounds for each of
those arms before we know what to do
next okay so in this case we're going to
define our upper confidence bounds by
being the empirical average plus the
square root of 2 log T T is the number
of times we pulled arms and NT of a is
the number of times we've sampled a
particular arm so this is total arm
pools this is particular so what is that
going to be in this case let's just
define it for each of them so you see B
of a 1 it's going to be equal to 1
because that's what we've got so far
plus square root 2 log of 3 because we
pulled 3 arms so far divided by 1 you
see B of a 2 is going to be the same
because we've also pulled that arm once
and it got the same outcome and then you
see B of a 3 is going to be different
because it's current reward is or
current expected value is 0 so it's just
gonna be equal to
to log three that by one that's how we
could instantiate each of the bounds and
now we've defined the upper confidence
bounds for each of the each of the arms
so in this case after we've done that
we're gonna pull one of these arms let's
say that we break tides randomly so the
upper confidence bound of a1 and a2 is
identical so with 50% probability we
select one with 50% probability we can
select the other and let's just compare
that for a second so if we're using UCB
I said that
so I'll just redefine this here so
people can remember it's equal to u CP
that's a 2 this is you see B stands for
upper confidence bound is equal to 1
plus square root 2 log 3 divided by 1
and you see B of a3 is equal to square
root 2 3 divided by 1 okay so why don't
we just take a second and define what
would be the probability of selecting a
charm if you're using a greedy with
epsilon equal point 1 and what about if
you're using UCB as always feel free to
talk to anybody nearby
all right so let's vote I'm going to ask
you to vote if if two arms have nonzero
probability or three arms have nonzero
probability so if you're using UCB do
two arms halves or non zero probability
three three arms have nonzero
probability somebody who knows who
thought with UCB you only have two arms
with nonzero probability when I explain
why yeah because you're making maximum
action okay one way to so if we're
picking the maximum action here we're
only going to pick action a1 or a2 we
have zero probability on the third arm
okay let's do a quick vote for Equis d4e
greedy do we have nonzero probability on
two arms on three arms that's right
what's the probability of so in the
point one in this case just remember we
normally defined that by uniformly
splitting yeah so we're gonna just have
a point 1 divided by the number of arms
so here why do I bring this up so I
bring this up to indicate that while UCB
is still splitting its attention among
all the arms that look good it's not
putting any weight right now on the arms
that it doesn't think could be good
which in this case is arm 3 whereas an e
greedy approach it's gonna put uniform
probability across anything it doesn't
think it's best so this is one of the
insights for why these algorithms might
be better it says there be more
strategic and how they're weighing what
arms to pull compared to what it what an
epsilon greedy which is just doing
uniform okay so let's look at sort of
what the regret would be in this case so
the actions we pulled is a1 a2 a3 a1 a2
so why would why would we pull a 2 again
let's just go through that briefly so
let's say
so first let's say we run out of pool a
and that's which one we picked okay so
we pulled a one let me just go through
one more step of what the upper
confidence bounds would be in this case
so let's say we pull a pulley one okay
so now we need to redefine the upper
confidence bounds we actually need to
redefine them for all the arms because
in the denominator of that upper
confidence bound it depends on T which
is the total number of pools or the
total number pulled so far if we're
using that form so now we're gonna have
that UCB let's say we pulled action a1
and let's say it got a 1 so you see B of
a1 is going to have the same mean which
is 1 plus square root 2 log 4 because
we've now pulled things 4 times but now
we pulled this arm twice so it's we're
gonna divide this by 2 you see B of a2
is going to have the same mean as before
because we didn't pull it and then it's
gonna also have the two log 4 we've only
pulled it once and you see B of A 3 it
still has the mean of 0 and it's also
gonna have to log 4 divided by 1 okay so
in this case what we're gonna find is
that we sort of began it was trading off
we still have the same empirical mean
for a1 and a2 but now we haven't pulled
a 2 as much as a1 so we're gonna flip
we're gonna pick a 2 now so that's why
if we imagine that we got well actually
as a quick check your understanding I
this result would happen whether we
picked one whether we got a 1 or 0 for
a1 when we last pulled it and so it's a
good thing to check is in shame but even
if we got a 1 for a 1 we'd still select
a 2 on the next round because the upper
confidence bound of it would drop even
if it's mean was the same so if we if we
look at this then so we're going to
compare it to what would be the optimal
action if we take him out the whole time
which is a1 so what is our regret I
regret is gonna be 0 then here it's
gonna be 0.05 which is just equal to
0.95 minus 0.9 here it's gonna be 0.85
because it's 0.95 minus 0.1 here it's
going to be 0 and here it is going to be
point oh
again that's how we'd sum up the gret
the regret of course we don't actually
know this I mean we can know this if
we're doing this in a simulated world
but we can't know this in reality
because again we actually knew it in
reality then we wouldn't have to be
doing this you would know the optimal
arm we have any other questions about
how UCB is working ok now just I guess
one other quick note here which is you
know these upper confidence bounds are
high probability bounds so they can fail
but it is possible that sometimes the
upper confidence bound is lower than the
true mean and so that's why when we did
the proof last time we had to talk about
sort of these different what happens if
the after competence bounds hold and and
there we did sort of a high probability
bound ok so an alternative would be to
always select the arm with the highest
lower bound so what we're doing right
now is just selecting the arm with the
highest upper bound but you could select
the arm with the best lower bound so
what might that look like
let's imagine that we have two arms a
one and a two and this is our estimate
of the queue of a so let's imagine that
these are our uncertainty bounds so in
this case a one has a higher upper bound
but a two has a higher lower bound so
why don't we take a minute or two and
think about why this could lead to
linear regret and a good two arm cases
the easiest one to think about for this
feel free to talk to anybody around you
if you want to brainstorm
and this is actually an important reason
why it's good to be optimistic at least
in reinforcement learning
okay so I talked to at least one person
the audience that need the right answer
which is um in this case if you select a
two you're going to continue to get
towards the mean the real mean is above
the lower bound of a one and so you're
gonna kind of get confirmation bias like
age who is going to continue to look
good and you're never your most like day
one so we're never going to get
information that allows us to disprove
our hypothesis and we're never going to
learn what the true optimal mean is so
that's why I can get linear regret so
one thing I just want to highlight is
that an upper confidence bounds are one
nice way to do optimism and they can
change over time in terms of hour per
bound but a simpler thing you might
imagine doing is just to initialize
things really to a high value um so
pretend for example the already observed
one pool of each of the arms and that it
was really really good
so just initialize all your values that
like a million or something like that
and then you just kind of average in
that weird fake pool when you're doing
your empirical average so you can
imagine you pretend you pull each of
your arms once you got a million you got
a trillion and then after that you just
average in all your empirical rewards so
this actually can work fairly well in a
lot of cases the challenge is to figure
out how optimistic you need to be for
that fake pool so just in terms of sort
of compare II and that approach to other
approaches recall that greedy gives you
linear total regret constant II greedy
can also give you linear total regret if
you de ke greedy you can get actually
sub linear regret if use the right
schedule for decay in epsilon but that
generally requires knowledge of the gaps
which are unknown so this is sort of
generally impossible to actually achieve
but if principle you know
it had an Oracle you could you could
figure out how to decay things if you do
hope to musk in the initialization
if you initialize the values
sufficiently optimistically then you can
achieve sublunary regret but again it
can be pretty subtle to figure out
exactly how optimistic those need to be
and I'll talk later about an example
where in that Markov decision process
case they have to be much more
optimistic than you might think they
would need to be in order for this to
work well all right so we're gonna now
start to talk about Bayesian bandits and
Bayesian regret and so far we've sort of
made very little assumptions about the
reward distribution we've assumed that
the rewards might be bounded so we
typically assume that the rewards are
gonna lie in sort of zero zero to one or
zero to some you know zero to R max or
something like that that we have bounded
rewards that you can't have infinite
rewards as nice as it would be but we
haven't been making strong parametric
assumptions over the distribution of
rewards tufting doesn't have training
requires the rewards to be bounded but
it doesn't assume for example if they're
Gaussian or Bernoulli or things like
that so an alternative approach is to
assume that we actually do have
information on the parametric
distribution of the rewards and exploit
that so we're gonna talk about Bayesian
bandits now where we sort of explicitly
compute a posterior over the rewards
given the history so given the previous
actions we or arms we pulled and the
rewards we've observed and given that
posterior we can use that posterior to
guide exploration and of course if your
prior knowledge is accurate that might
help you there's sort of somewhat of a
debate between frequentist and Bayesian
views of the world we're not going to
get really too much into that in this
class but the idea is it's also gonna be
a nice way to put in prior knowledge if
you have prior knowledge about the
particular word structure of your
environment you can put this in and it
can help in terms of exploration okay so
in the Bayesian view now we're just
gonna do sort of a quick review of
Bayesian inference a number of you guys
it's probably a refresher for some
people it might be new we're gonna
assume that we have a prior over the
unknown cram
so in our case the unknown parameters
are going to be the parameters that
determine the reward probability
distribution for each of the arms and
the idea is that given sort of
observations or data about that
parameter like observing rewards when
you pull an arm we're going to update
our uncertainty over the unknown
parameters using Bayes rule so let's
look at that as a specific example so
for example imagine that the reward of
an arm eye is a probability distribution
that depends on some unknown parameter
Phi I so notice this is unknown I'm
gonna have some initial prior over Phi I
which is the probability of Phi I so
this is before we pulled that arm at all
this is sort of our uncertainty over
that parameter and then we pull our mi
we observe a particular reward our i1
and then we can use this to update our
estimate of the distribution over the
parameters that determine our reward
probability distribution for this arm so
we do that using Bayes rule and we say
that the posterior probability of our
parameters Phi I given that we've
observed that reward is equal to our
prior probability over those times of
our data evidence or a likelihood
divided by the probability of observing
that reward regardless of what your
parameters were and so this is Bayes
rule and I the challenge or the
important thing here is how do we
compute all of those things so that
tells us how to update our posterior
over the parameters and the question is
how do we do this so in general doing
this sort of updating can be very tricky
to do because if you don't have any
structure on the sort of parametric form
of the prior and the data likelihood so
this again is the prior and this is the
data likelihood
if you have no structure on this one of
them's a deep neural network another one
of them is some random other parametric
distribution then it may be impossible
to have a closed form representation for
what the posterior is so in general this
can be really hard but it turns out that
there's particular forms at the prior
and the data likelihood that mean that
we can do this analytically so who
here's familiar with conjugates okay
some people but not everybody so these
are really cool conjugates exponential
families for example are our conjugate
distributions the idea is that if the
parametric representation of the prior
and and the posterior is the same we
call the prior in the model conjugate so
what would that mean so for example what
if this is like a Gaussian if this is a
Gaussian and this is a Gaussian then we
would say that this in this or conjugate
whatever thing we're using for the data
likelihood essentially means that we can
do this posterior update updating
analytically or in closed form just
really nice so we call it this means
that we sort of keep things on the same
parametric family as we're getting more
evidence about these hidden parameters
I'll give an example of this in a second
but there are a number of different
parametric families which have conjugate
priors which means that if you have an
initial uncertainty over the the
parameter in that distribution then if
you observe some data you can update it
in your syllabus a parametric family so
there's super-elegant come up in
statistics a lot um alright so here's a
particular example that's relevant to us
which is Bernoulli's so let's think
about a bandit problem where the reward
of an arm is just a binary outcome and
that this is sampled from a Bernoulli
with a parameter theta so this comes up
a lot this is things like advertisement
click-through rates patient treatment
succeeds or fails etc so many many cases
we when we pull an arm where we take an
action we're gonna get a binary reward
either 0 or 1 so it turns out that the
beta distribution beta alpha beta is
conjugate for the Bernoulli distribution
that means we can write down our prior
over the Bernoulli parameter given alpha
and beta as follows
it's theta to the alpha minus 1 1 minus
theta to the beta minus 1 times a ratio
of the gammas gammas are related to the
factorial factorial distribution so all
of this can be computed analytically and
one nice way I think to think about this
is that we can think of alpha and beta
is essentially being the result of prior
pools of the arm so we can use them also
to encode sort of prior information
about this and I'll show you shortly an
example of how these get updated but
what happens is that if you assume that
the prior over theta is a beta so if it
looks like this this is the prior then
if you observe a reward that's in 0 1
because that's what our just rewards are
whenever we sample 1 then the updated
posterior over theta is a really nice
form it's just the same beta
distribution with either one added to
the alpha or one added to the beta so
essentially if you observe or equal 1
then you get beta of alpha plus 1 beta
if you observe R equals 0 you instead
add it to the beta turn so you can think
of alphas as mean all the number of
times that you saw a reward of 1 and
beta is is all the number of times you
saw a reward of Sara explained how the
fact that theta was Bernoulli factored
into this description and why this isn't
just like the description of a beta
distribution the main equation like why
it was important to first say that theta
is Bernoulli I'm bringing up that a
great question so the the reason I bring
this up is that beta is a conjugate
prior for the Bernoulli so if the ideas
and in this case if we're thinking about
an arm which has binary outcomes then we
could think of the average of that arm
has been represented by a Bernoulli
parameter so let's say like 0.7 percent
you know on average point seven times we
get a reward of 1 and 0.3 we get a
reward of 0
so or the mean of that arm is 0.7 okay
so we're thinking about an arm which it
has a Bernoulli parameter that describes
its mean
so we're thinking of like you know an
arm with mean equal to theta that's what
the mean is for a Bernoulli distribution
and what I'm saying is that we want to
now be Bayesian about that and we want
to think about what is the probability
of that parameter given the data we've
seen so far and if we want to be able to
update our estimate over theta naught
over rewards over theta then we're gonna
write down our distribution over what
they does might be possible as a beta
distribution and then we're gonna update
that as we see evidence and I'll show
you shortly
like what these betas look like so we
can think of sir what is the probability
distribution over Thetas as we get more
evidence so for example you might
imagine if you see a reward which is 1 1
1 1 1 1 1 then your beta distribution is
going to indicate that a theta which is
really high is more likely if you get 0
0 0 0 0 your and your beta is gonna have
a different shifted posterior which is
gonna say probably your theta is really
low close to 0 cool
so we'll see an example of this in just
a second so the nice thing in this case
is that for Bernoulli's which is a
really common distribution that we often
want to think about we can write down a
prior over that parameter and we can
update it analytically just using the
counts so we just keep track of how many
times we've seen a 1 or how many times
we have a zero and we use that to update
our posterior okay so how do we evaluate
performance now we're in this Bayesian
setting so in the frequentist regret we
didn't think about having distributions
over parameters we just thought of there
being some parameter like you know
what's the mean of that arm and then we
defined our regret with respect to the
best arm bayesian regret assumes there's
this prior over parameters and so
Bayesian regret says what is my expected
regret by thinking about what are the
possible parameters given my prior and
then looking at the expected performance
if I got a particular theta so it's a
little bit different way of looking at
the world again we're not gonna really
get into the philosophical aspects of
this but Bayesian regret is saying like
well we're not sure you know what the
distributions are these arms and
there'll be different worlds in which
they'll take on different values and how
will do you do in those different worlds
on average alright so how do we try to
make good decisions for Bayesian bandits
so one thing you might imagine is let's
say we have a parametric distribution
over the rewards for each of the arms we
could have we could certainly have that
in the Bayesian case the idea of
probability matching which I think it's
been around since the brown 1929 it's
been around a long time like almost a
hundred years is that we want to select
an action a according to the probability
that it's optimal so it seems quite
intuitively appealing like we want to
select arms that might be optimal more
we want to select arms that probably
aren't likely to be optimal less and it
is optimistic in the face of uncertainty
because in general uncertain actions
have a higher probability of being the
best so uncertain actions mean we don't
know very much about what their rewards
are the problem is this sounds really
nice we'd like to sort of select arms
according to the probability that
they're optimal but it's completely
unclear how to compute that so this
expression here is saying we want to
sample an arm given a history so the
history or here is prior pools and
reward outcomes so this is the history
of arms we pooled and whether we've got
what sort of rewards we've gotten and
then we want to pull an arm according to
the probability that that arm is better
than all the other arms given that
history so that's quite intellectually
appealing but it's not at all clear how
we would compute that quantity and so
it's sort of somewhat magical that a
very simple approach turns out to
implement probability matching and the
idea is called Thompson sampling and
again this came out you know roughly in
the 1920s and one of the really
interesting aspects of that is it sort
of
disappeared for a long time in terms of
bandits certainly in the AI community in
CS community and then around eight years
ago eight to nine years ago people sort
of got reinterred in understanding these
and in part due to a paper that a
colleague of mine published which you'll
see results up shortly which indicated
that empirically it can be really good
okay so how does Thompson sampling work
we're gonna neutralize a prior for each
of the arms often we'd like this to be
conjugate it doesn't have to be it's
nice if it's conjugate but we're gonna
have a probability over each of the arms
now remember that this is sort of a
probability over the parameters
determining a distribution so it could
be if we have Bernoulli arms it could be
the probability of theta I for I equals
1 to the number of arms so for example
this could be a beta distribution of 1 1
we could say the probability that my I
farm has a Bernoulli parameter theta is
equal to sampling from a beta 1 1 okay
so we're going to pick a particular
parametric family to represent our prior
distribution know the reward
distributions of each of the arms and
then what we do is for each route we
first sample a rewards distribution from
that posterior again we'll go through a
concrete example of this in a second but
this is like picking a particular theta
so it's like saying I'm assuming that my
mean for this arm or my Bernoulli
parameter for this arm is 0.7 looking a
particular value for that parameter and
then once you have that you can compute
the action value function by just taking
the mean of whatever that is so notice
that if theta let's say we sample for
arm 1 let's say we sample 0.9 we just
happen semble that arm one has a theta
parameter 0.9 well the queue for arm 1
is then going to be the expected value
of a Bernoulli
data one which is just point nine
because the expected value for a
Bernoulli variable is just P just that
just that theta so we're going to
compute the action value function for
each of these in the case of a Gaussian
it would just be its mean for example so
you just compute what the mean expected
reward is for each of the arms under the
particular word distribution we sampled
and then you take whichever action looks
best for those sampled parameters so
that's this and then we take that action
and we observe a reward and then we
update our posterior using Bayes law so
we're just gonna take our priors over
the parameters we're gonna sample a
particular set of parameters these are
probably totally wrong this is just us
making up what the actual you know
parameters are for each of the arms then
we act as if that world is optimal we
get some data we repeat so it's a it's a
fairly simple thing to do we of course
have to see how we can do this sampling
and I'll show you an example with
Bernoulli's in a second but no we're
here are we trying to explicitly compute
like what is the posterior probability
that this arm is optimal
we're just sampling some and then we're
gonna be sort of greedy with respect to
those samples so Thompson's sampling
turns out to implement probability
matching which is super cool and for
some of the intuition of this so this is
what probability matching is probability
matching is that we want to select an
action given the history according to
the probability that it's optimal
according to the probability that arm
really is the best arm and we can think
of that as being equivalent to the
expected value of picking a reward given
the H and that are the are M is equal to
the Arg max of Q a given that history
and that's what Thompson sampling is
computing okay so let's see how this
actually looks for the broken toe
example because I think that'll make it
a lot more concrete so again in this
case remember that we have three
different arms and they each are looking
at the success or failure of doing this
treatment to try to make
people's broken toes better and surgery
is a bernoulli parameter with 0.95
taping is 0.9 and nothing is 0.1 so if
we want to then run Thompson assembly in
this environment remember it doesn't
know what those actual parameters are
we're gonna choose a beta 1 1 prior over
the parameters so that means that we're
gonna say the probability of you know 1
is equal to a beta okay so what does a
beta 1 1 look like it looks like a
uniform distribution so this is 0 to 1
this is Theta this is probability to do
that so what this says is that if
someone gives you a beta 1 1
distribution it says you're gonna select
a Bernoulli parameter from that I have
no idea what its value is it could be 0
it could be 1 and carry point 5 it's
sort of an uninformative prior okay so
it says that initially I have no idea
what these theta parameters might be for
each of the arms so I'm just going to
pretend it's I'm gonna start off an
assume it's flat I have no information
okay so this is what a beta 1 1 looks
like but what's going to happen in
Thompson sampling so this is our
distribution over Thetas and what
Thompson sembly is going to do is it's
going to sample our parameter from that
distribution so in this case it's just a
uniform distribution between 0 & 1 so
we're just going to select some value
between 0 & 1
so in this case imagine what we got is
I'll just leave this up for a second so
people can see 0.3 0.5 and 0.6 there's
no reason that arm 3 would be higher or
lower than arm one arm to arm 3 in
reality arm 1 is best but we have no
information about that so far we have no
rewards so far all we've done is we've
just said I have a uniform distribution
over what my data parameter might be a
sample from it and so in this case it's
like sampling and you got this value
once you got this value once and you got
this value once
all right we just sampled from that
distribute that uniform distribution and
these are the parameters we picked and
now we're going to pretend that's real
so we're gonna say I'm going to pretend
that my theta for surgery is 0.3 my
theta for taping is 0.5 and my theta for
nothing is 0.6 so if that was the real
world we lived in what arm would we
select turn on exactly
so in this world the third arm really is
best because that's the fate of 0.6 okay
so we're gonna select theta is point 6
using uninformative priors because I
could have very well using beta 2 2 or a
5/5 so yeah so
he makes a really good point she said
we're currently using unimportant of
prior is it better or worse to do that
compared to using an informative prior
so you could have had like a beta of
like three four etc a beta of three four
or anything that's not one one is gonna
give you it's gonna biased your
distribution it's gonna change the shape
of how you sample things if you have
actually good information that can be
really useful because it's essentially
like having fake polls and it can guide
sort of your initial samples the
downside is that if that isn't correct
you can be misled for a while so we
often talk about like how robust are we
to misspecified priors or to wrong
priors and so using that uninformative
prior means that you're not getting a
lot of benefit from prior knowledge but
you're also not going to get a
disadvantage okay so in this case we're
gonna select the arm arm three because
that's just the arm that has the best
expected mean under the samples that we
did okay but arm three is actually not
very good and we know that because arm
three actually only has a reward of 0.1
and so when we sample it and we get the
patient's outcome we're going to get a
zero it's a particular case because the
real arm three is 0.1 so if we sample
from abuddin really with 0.1 most of the
time we're going to get a zero so now
what we have to do is we have to update
our posterior over arm three okay we
have to update what sort of what are our
probability of theta of arm three is
given that the reward was equal to zero
so what we talked about is that the beta
is a conjugate prior for the Bernoulli
and if we observe or one we're going to
update the first parameter elsewhere
we're gonna update the second parameter
so we just saw zero so our new beta is
one two because we just saw a zero so we
update so this is our new parameter
that's our new posterior over the arm
three and it looks like this okay so
this is still theta it always has to be
between zero one because this is a
Bernoulli parameter and this is what the
probability looks like now so notice
that ship
did so it used to be flat and now it
says well no I just observed that we got
a reward of zero so now I have a higher
probability that theta is small so if I
was gonna sample from this it is more
likely I would get a lower value
compared to a higher value unlike before
so this is our new posterior and what
does the posterior look like for the
other arms so this is 4 this is 4 theta
3 and for the other two
they still look uniform because there's
still a beta 1 1 so for beta 1 1 this is
for the other arms theta 1 theta 2
misses probability of theta the other
two are still uniform because we we
haven't pulled them yet we don't have
any outcomes so they still look like
uniform distributions but the
probability over theta 3 looks skewed
towards 0 so now in Thompson sampling we
again are just gonna sample a value from
each of these different ones each of
those three distributions and now
imagine we get point seven point five
and point three yeah should I think P or
Q vapor yeah there's a couple errors
there yep thanks for catching man any
other questions okay so we updated our
posterior over arm three our posterior
over arm one and arm two is the same as
the prior because we didn't we didn't
pull them okay so now we're gonna sample
from those three distributions what
Thompson family would say is now given
our posterior over all of the arms let's
select an actual parameter for each of
the arm and this time we're going to get
point seven point five and point three
so which arm where we gonna select this
time arm one right so now the max is
going to be arm one so now we're gonna
have a posterior that looks like beta to
one because we update our beta and
remember we can just think of this as
bead then
of R equals ones plus one because we
started with the beta 1 1 and this is
the number of R equals 0 's plus 1 so
now our new posterior for this one makes
it look like it says so this is theta 1
it's 1 0 probability of theta 1 ok so
now as we would expect we saw that arm 1
had a good outcome and so our
probability that that Bernoulli
parameter is higher than 0.5 is going up
because we saw some positive results ok
so now we have so what does our new
distributions look like we have a beta
to 1 we have a beta 1 1 because we
haven't selected arm 2 yet and then we
have a beta 1 2 all right so what's
going to happen next
lívia again are gonna sample it
Bernoulli parameter so let's imagine
that we got 0.7 one point six five and
point one and so that means we're again
going to select arm 1 and we again
observe a1 surgery is pretty effective
and now our posterior is 3 1 so now this
again is 0 to 1 this is our probability
if they don't wonder ok so now it's
looking even more peaked so what's your
guess of what's the next arm were likely
to sample so remember the three
distributions we have right now is for
arm to looks like this for arm 3 looks
like this so this is the probability of
that arm since theta a 2 theta 3 0 1 0 1
so who thinks that theta 1 is again
going to be sampled and look better than
everything else that's right because
it's guy have it has a posterior over
its Bernoulli parameter that is getting
closer but more and more steep towards 1
theta 2 we've still never taken it we
still never taken action a 2 but it just
has a uniform probability so it's very
unlikely that we're gonna sample a value
for it that is better than the value we
sampled for arm 1 so again in this case
imagine sampling again we get a point
seven five point four five point four we
select action a1 again and now we have a
beta for one that's looking even more
sharp up so notice this is quite
different than what you see V was doing
you see B was splitting its time between
a1 and two it at the beginning because
that we're both reliant on their
empirical means but then a2 had been
taken less times in this case we still
haven't taken action a to yet and it may
be hard for us to pull it for a while
now that's not necessarily the best
great question is like okay so here
we've got binary rewards how would we do
this if the things were not binary in
that case we wouldn't use a beta and a
Bernoulli so if you didn't have four
binary words bernoulli's a really nice
choice and betas conjugate if you have
real valued rewards you might use a
Gaussian and then you'd have a Gaussian
prior depending on whether you know your
theta or not and in general like for
multinomial you can use Dursley
distributions it depends on what your
award distribution looks like and then
you want to find a conjugate prior for
that distribution so there's a lot of
different families of parametric
distributions for which you can do this
sort of updating
about being optimistic yeah and here we
use like a uniform distribution for
initialization is it better to use
something more optimistic that's a great
question this question was so we talked
before about the benefits of optimism
here we just used a uniform prior and I
wouldn't be better to use one that is
optimistic it depends
either empirically what so what is this
doing I'm just gonna let me hold on that
question for a second so we can look at
sort of what these look like so if we
did optimism we slam fold all the
actions first and then we sort of got
this interleave you know of a 1 or n a 2
in Thompson Sam Lane
we took a 3 and then we took a 1 a 1 a 1
a 1 and a 1 a 1 a 1 a 1 a 1 is optimal
in this case so by using a uniform prior
here essentially as soon as you see
something that looks pretty good like
better than 0.5 you're gonna tend to
often sample it a lot more so you're
sort of exploiting faster to some extent
you can put priors in there the question
is often like how much to put that in
there and if it actually helps so one of
the cool things with Thompson sampling
is it turns out in terms of sort of the
Bayesian regret found they're as good as
the upper confidence bounds but
empirically often exploding faster is
helpful so you could put optimism in
there but it might actually hurt
performance because it's gonna force you
to take like in this case arm one
actually is optimal now you could have
imagined maybe we were just lucky there
and instead we've got an a2 when that
case you'd want something to help you
eventually take a1 now note we we will
still take a to likely at some point
because there still will be a
probability under that uniform prior
that you'll sample like 0.999 then
you'll take a two so you can still be
sure to start taking other actions even
you seen these uniform priors but it's a
really good question about sort of you
know weird what information to put in
there yeah
oh yes bad life here your Netflix that
it becomes very hot for depression to
catch up so no so that since that can
set a start it's more important again
really good one which is okay so maybe
if one arm is really good then it
becomes really hard for the other arms
to catch up so in this case that's true
because
theta-1 really does have 0.95 let's
imagine a slightly different case where
this would like point seven or something
like that then in that case over time it
would be likely they your beta
distribution is going to converge to
around the real distribution of the
parameter so if you keep sampling theta
one forever eventually you know it's
gonna sort of collapse towards what the
true value is and so if the true value
isn't very close to one there will be
some probability you'll sample like so
imagine this versus a uniform
that's not very close to one at some
point there is a nonzero probability
that you'd sample something that's
higher so the beginning matters but you
couldn't help lay it over time just like
what we can with the empirical
distributions
okay so if we look at this and we sort
of look at the incurred frequent to
spread which is not the same as Bayesian
regret because in that case we'd have to
average over the parameters in this case
Thompson sampling is doing a lot better
so in this case here this would be 0.85
and that would be 0 0 0 0 in this case
Thompson sampling would be doing a much
better job now
Thompson sampling I actually does
achieve the lion Robbins lower bound for
the performance of an algorithm so in
terms of its lower bound is similar so
that's one indication this might be a
good algorithm we are there's a lot of
bounds for optimism in general the the
balancer optimism are better than the
bounds for Thompson sampling a lot of
the Thompson sampling bounds end up
converting to sort of upper confidence
valance a little bit like some was
asking so if we if you want to make
Thompson sampling have frequentist like
bounce often we end up sort of make
our comfort our sort of being more
optimistic in terms of Thompson sampling
interpret those but empirically Thompson
sampling there's often great can you mix
Thompson sampling than upper competence
bound so there's some predominance down
and use that information to update like
your tires on the tops exactly I listen
to say can you could you mix them you
probably could I you could probably do
it I don't know it so I guess to me one
of the so maybe you could start with
upper competence bass and then use
Thompson sampling to me one of the big
benefits of Thompson sampling
empirically is that it is less
optimistic and upper confidence bounds
our pro confidence bounds tend to be too
optimistic for too long it's like oh you
know I ran into the door thirty thousand
times
maybe the thirty thousand and one time I
won't you know like for your robot or
something like that so it often tends to
sort of think about the extreme events
whereas if you know that say the world
is really Gaussian like the probability
that your robots gonna run into a wall
again it's still really high even if
it's only run into the wall ten times so
maybe should to pick a different path so
I think often you probably would want to
start with Thompson sampling but you
would like to be robust to your prior
and so some work that tries to combine
these ideas as known as pack Bayesian
where you try to get I'll define what
pack is in a second but um you'll try to
get bounce that are kind of frequent
just like but also get the best of both
worlds so you'd like to be like Bayesian
if your prior is really good and unpack
if you like sort of frequentist if it
turns out that your priors run so one of
the papers that I think sort of changed
a lot of people's minds about Bayesian
and bandits and also Thompson's sampling
being a good idea was this paper by my
colleague Lee hugly and also a Chappelle
where they looked at contextual bandits
and will hopefully get to this for a
little bit on Wednesday but the idea in
contextual bandits is that you have a
state and in action so it's a little bit
different than the bandits we've seen so
far
unlike in MDPs your action does not
affect the next state so for those of
you doing the default project you're
seeing examples of this where how you
treat the current patient doesn't impact
the next patient that comes along but
the patient characteristics can affect
which arm is best so so contextual
bandits is a very popular and power
full framework and so in this case they
were looking at news article
recommendations and they were finding
Thompson sampling did much better than
upper confidence bounds and a number of
other algorithms it also can be more
robust when your outcomes are delayed so
this happens a lot often in real cases
you could imagine you you treat a
patient you're not gonna find out
whether or not that toe procedure helps
for another six weeks but in the
meantime other people come in whose toes
need to be treated and if you use our
per competence bound algorithms they
tend to be deterministic bless you and
and so you just keep treating everybody
with the same thing until you get the
outcome from the first whereas
Thompson's sampling is stochastic so you
will be sort of trying out a lot of
things that's another good reason in
practice why Thompson's sampling can be
helpful okay so I'm not going to go
through the proof today but I'll put
some pointers that the nice thing is
that if you look at the Bayesian regret
of Thompson sampling it's gonna have a
similar result to what
upper confidence bounce has so it
essentially has has the same ignorant
regrets bounds as you see be essentially
I've been slightly hand waving for that
there's some important subtle details
but roughly you can show that these also
have good Bayesian regret bounds if your
priors correct and so that's sort of
again a nice sanity check you kind of
get this logarithmic regret growth all
right another framework that I just
mentioned sort of in passing just now is
probably approximately correct
so these theoretical regret bounds
specify how your regret grows over time
and one thing that's hard to know is
whether you're making a lot of small
mistakes or a few big mistakes your
regret bounds are cumulative so it
doesn't allow you to distinguish between
those two so you can imagine that use of
patient treatments this can be pretty
important like are you giving everybody
a headache or are few patients really
you know having really really bad side
effects so so regret cumulative regret
doesn't distinguish between those two
because if a couple people have really
bad side effects that's the same as a
lot of people having headaches when you
average over those and so one idea is to
say well maybe we just want to kind of
bound the number of non-small errors so
we want to bound the number of people
that experience
it's really bad side effects for example
so probably approximately correct comes
up in supervised learning in the context
of decision-making we often define it as
follows I probably approximately correct
algorithm or PAC states that the
algorithm will choose an action who is
which is epsilon close to optimal with
probabilities one minus Delta an all but
a polynomial number of steps so the
probability part comes from here so it's
not guaranteeing that you will do this
but with high confidence or probably it
will do this it's approximately correct
because we're only guaranteeing epsilon
optimality and the important aspect is
this only does makes these sort of makes
mistakes that might be bigger than
Epsilon so the number of you know
patients we might treat that have really
really bad side effects is going to be
no more than a polynomial function where
the polynomial function is a function of
the parameters of your domain so things
like the number of actions you have
epsilon and Delta and you should be able
to compute this in advance too so you
should be able to compute how many
mistakes you might make and one of the
cool things is that you do a lot of the
PAC algorithms algorithms that are PAC
are based on optimism or Thompson
sampling now PAC for bandits is a much
less common approach than when we go to
MVPs in bandits most of the time we look
at regret but for when we look at Markov
decision processes PAC is more popular
and we'll see one of the reasons for
that persuader or feel free to ask me
about if we don't get to it today okay
so what would pack look like in our
little example we had here before so
let's use odor denote optimism TS to
denote Thompson sampling and within
epsilon means that the action that we
select is within epsilon of the optimal
action so it's value is epsilon close to
the optimal action so I've written down
the regret in this case here what we
would have is that the for optimism the
first action that we pull is a1 so it's
within epsilon yes because
were close to the optimal action hu has
a mean of 0.9 so that's within 0.05 0.95
so this is yes action a3 is 0.1 so it's
not within epsilon of the optimal action
so this is no and so forth so this
essentially allows the algorithm to be
taking either action 1 or action a2
under this definition of epsilon says I
don't care whether or not you're taking
action a1 or a2 both of them are really
pretty good
both them within point O 5 of each other
I mean that's fine
but you we don't want you to take action
3 very much because it's much worse and
then in this case this one would say
this is not within epsilon because the
first action we take is bad and then all
the rest are good and what a pack
approach would do would they be counting
all these counting the mistakes ok so we
just talked about four bandits different
sorts of frameworks and criterias we
talked about regret
Bayesian regret and pack and we talked
about two styles of approaches either
optimism or Thompson sampling and what
we can see now is that Markov decision
processes have many of the same sorts of
ideas being applicable but it also does
get a lot more challenging so in
particular what we're going to talk
about right now is we're gonna talk
about tabular mdps and it turns out that
even from with tabular mdps that things
are a lot more subtle so how does this
work the regret the Bayesian regret
impact is all going to be applicable
so is optimism and so is probability
matching so let's start with thinking
about optimism under uncertainty first
let's think about just drawing
optimistic initialization so in this
case imagine that we just initialize all
of our cue state actions to some value
so let's imagine that we initialize them
to our max divided by 1 minus gamma or
our max is the highest reward you could
see in any state action
let's just take one minute why is that
value guaranteed to be optimistic
anybody want to answer why that's
guaranteed to be optimistic yeah hired
and like the possible total value
because like we've showed a couple times
the heart of x1 - scandal would be -
that's right that is correct and we've
shown that for a discounted Markov
decision process that the highest value
could get is our max divided by one
minus gamma at best all of your states
have that or else some of them might not
so this is guaranteed to be an
optimistic value so you could start off
and you've initialized all of your state
action values to be our max divided by
one minus gamma and then you can do
Monte Carlo you can do q-learning sarsa
and you can incrementally update using
that and this can be very helpful it can
sort of encourage systematic exploration
of states and actions because
essentially you're pretending that
everything the world is really awesome
until proven otherwise
so on the downside unfortunately if you
do this in general there's no guarantees
on performance even though it's often
empirically better so even though this
really is you know an upper bound this
is optimistic a key issue is how quickly
you're updating from those optimistic
values so as an early result in this
case even Darin manzoor in 2002 proved
that if you run Q learning with learning
rates they should say alpha so if you
run chillin with particular alpha rates
alpha I on each time step I and you
initialize the value of the state so
this is the very beginning to be R max
divided by 1 minus gamma times the
product of those learning rates and T is
the number of samples you need to learn
optimal Q then greedy only Q learning is
pack with that initialize
so I just want to highlight something
here which is this part so notice this
is way way way larger than just our max
over 1 minus gamma because this is a
product of all your learning weights so
this could be really enormous like you'd
imagine that imagine that alpha is equal
to 0.1 for all time steps then what you
have here is you have 1 over 0.1 to the
T does approximately it which is equal
to 10 to the T so this is like
exponential in the number of time steps
you're gonna make decisions
it was incredibly optimistic it turns
out this is sufficient to be PAC but
it's also not very good I it's it's very
very extremely large okay now but spins
a really cool work by Chi Jin and some
others over at Berkeley that showed that
if you use a less optimistic
initialization I'm that strongly related
to upper confidence bounds and you were
careful about your learning rates so you
have to change your learning rates but
if you're careful about your learning
rates they prove that model of free Q
learning could also be PAC and this was
a pretty big deal recently because
almost all of the work that's been going
on has been in the model base setting so
this just came out interrupts about two
months ago and so they are saying that
PAC they showed regret bounds they're
not optimal regret bounds but they're
good so that they're not tight yet but
it shows that model free algorithms can
do pretty well okay so what about
model-based approaches and the
model-based approaches for mdps are the
ones where you really have the best
bounds right now so there's a couple
main ideas or a couple different
procedures we could go with what is that
you could be really really optimistic
and all your estimates until you're
confident that your empirical estimates
of your dynamics and reward model are
close to the true dynamics and Wardwell
parameters so these sort of algorithms
proceed as if they say the reward for
all state action pairs is amazing it's R
max divided by one minus gamma and I'm
going to continue to pretend that
true until I think I have enough data
for that state action pair that I think
that if I did a MLE
maximum likelihood estimate of those
parameters they would be close to the
true parameters so you could say I'm
just gonna be incredibly optimistic
until I've got enough data and then when
I've got enough data then I think I can
get a good empirical estimate that is
close to the true estimate and then I'll
use those instead so it's almost kind of
like a switching point you sort of keep
a you pretend everything's really really
great until you get enough data and then
you switch over to the empirical
estimate so these were some of the
earliest ones that showed that MDPs
could be pal girls for EM DPS could be
pack syndrome 2002 but they're also
empirically not normally so good because
you're pretending things are really
really awesome even though you might
have quite a lot of evidence for that
state action pair that it's not awesome
so another approach is to be optimistic
given the information you have so what
do I mean by that I mean that as your
agent walks around and gathers
observations of the actions and rewards
it gets it uses that to try to estimate
how good the world could be given that
data and so one approach to this is to
compute confidence sets on dynamics and
rewards models so we already saw this
for bandits where we computed upper and
lower confident or we could compute
upper and lower confidence bounds for
their rewards turns out we can also
compute confident sets over the dynamics
model or we could just add reward
bonuses that depend on the experience or
data and I'm going to talk at least a
little bit today before we finish about
this second thing and the reason I'm
going to talk about this particular
approach is because when we start to
think about doing this in the function
approximation setting if the way that
your dynamics model is represented is by
a deep neural network then writing down
uncertainties over that can be really
tricky and also a lot of the progress in
deep neural networks for RL focus on
model free approaches and if we have
reward bonuses then we can easily extend
that to the model free case and
empirically these ones didn't really do
pretty much as well as if we use
explicit confidence sets
so I'm just gonna explain how the model
based confidence model based interval
estimation with exploration bonus works
so it's gonna assume that we're given an
epsilon Delta and some constant M and
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
initialize some counts so this is just
gonna keep track of the number of times
we've seen a state action pair so we're
gonna do this for all s and for all a
we're also gonna keep track of the
number of times we've seen an axe state
action next state pair zero for all s
for all a Pearl S prime and we're also
going to keep track of the total summer
of rewards we've gotten from any state
an action pair so we're gonna say are C
the best a is equal to 0 for all s so
essentially we're going to keep track of
the times that we've been in any state
taking any action and went to any next
state and what this summer rewards are
for when we've done that and then we're
gonna define a beta parameter double
check I get the
all right so beta is gonna be a
parameter that we're going to use to
define our reward bonuses I am in sum 1
over 1 minus gamma to log the number of
states number of actions 2 times M and
it's an input parameter divided by Delta
and then yeah I think that's all I need
so I'm gonna say T equal to 0 we're
gonna initialize our state and to start
we can just say QT of si it's equal to
c1 divided by 1 minus gamma and this
assumes that all of our words are
bounded between 0 and 1 so they're
bounded rewards okay so we start off
when we initialize all our accounts to 0
we say we have an observed in your words
yet and we pretend that the world is
awesome and that our Q value is the
highest it could possibly be in every
state action pair here our max is equal
to 1 so our max is going to equal to 1
because our rewards are bounded between
0 and 1 so what we do then is we take an
action in the current state given our
two Tilda's given our Q function so the
beginning we're just going to break ties
randomly and then we're gonna observe
the reward and observe the next state
and then we just update our accounts so
we update our accounts for that
particular state action pair we update
our accounts for sa s prime s a s prime
for the number of times we've been in
that state taking that action and went
to that particular next state and then
we update our rewards for that state
action pair is equal to the previous
rewards for that state action pair plus
RT and then what we're going to do is
we're going to use those empirical
counts to define an empirical transition
model
empirical reward model so our reward
model is going to just be the Emily
reward model which is just gonna be our
c4 si divide x divided by the number of
times we've been in that state action
pair that's just the average reward for
that state action pair and then our
transition model is also just going to
be the number of times a s prime divided
by the number of times you've been in
that state action bear
we're just gonna define our empirical
transition model and our empirical
reward model and it doesn't matter how
we initialize things that we haven't
seen it all but you can treat them as
uniform okay so we're gonna do this for
all SA and then we're gonna compute some
UQ functions and we're gonna compute
some UQ functions where we do this where
we take our empirical models and we also
add in a reward bonus term that depends
on beta and the number of times we've
tried that state action pair and we can
do value iteration that's what I'm doing
here but you could solve it however
you'd like but the main idea here is
that we're gonna use our empirical
estimates of the reward model in the
transition model by just averaging our
counts or averaging the rewards we've
gotten for that state action pair and
then we're gonna add in this is a reward
bonus and note at the beginning this
reward bonus can be really like it can
be infinity so you can because if we
have no counts for that so then we can
just initialize for for any Q si so for
all si such that n si si is equal to
zero you can just set this to be Q max
so to deal with what if you haven't
sampled that state action pair yet so
that means anything for which that you
haven't sampled yet is going to look
maximally awesome and anything else is
going to be a combination of its
empirical averaged parameters plus a
reward bonus and that reward bonus is
going to get smaller as we have more
data so I'll put this on here where it
will be neater so this is the reward
bonus and what you can see here is that
over time that's going to shrink and
over time you're going to get closer and
closer to using the empirical estimates
for a particular state action pair but
for state action pairs you haven't tried
very much there's going to be a large
reward bonus
so the the cool thing about this is that
we can think about whether it's PAC so
I'll just take one more a minute which
is in an RL case an algorithm is PAC if
on all the end time steps the action
selected is epsilon closed the optimal
action where n is a polynomial function
of these things the number of states the
number of actions gamma epsilon a delta
this is not true for all algorithms
greedy is not Peck greedy can be
exponential we might talk about that on
Wednesday so no and the nice thing is
that the MBI e eb algorithm I just
showed you is PAC so what does it pack
in it means that on all put this number
of time steps I'll just circle it so
this is sort of a large ugly expression
but it is polynomial the number of
states and actions it's also a function
of the discount factor and the epsilon
in general if you want to be closer to
optimal it's going to take you more data
to ensure that you're close to optimal
so it's inversely dependent on epsilon
it's Paula normally dependent on state
connections and this says on all but
this many time steps your algorithm is
going to be taking actions that are
close to optimal so this is pretty cool
it sounds like by just using these
average estimates plus tacking on a
bonus term and then computing the Q
functions then you can actually act
really well on all time steps that set
for a polynomial number okay and then I
put in here this your theoretical of
that and I'll just say briefly that on
some sort of hard to construct sort of
simple toy domains these type of
algorithms do much better even than some
other ones that are provably efficient
and they can do much much better than
things like greedy so algorithms like
MBIA b m bi e is a related one that uses
competent sets can do much much better
than this is sort of B be optimistic
until competent and these ones are
generally much better than greedy so
these types of optimistic algorithms
empirically be much better as well as
being provably better and on Wednesday
we'll start to talk about how to combine
them a generalization Thanks